it is May 11 2023 and you're watching
the code report we have no moat and open
source models will win the great AI War
that's according to a leaked Memo from a
Google employee based on the
announcements at Google I O yesterday I
think they got the memo you've been
applying AI to make ai ai generative AI
third ai employing ai finally rigorously
tested AI with AI large language models
with AI power of AI alternative ai ai
platforms AI Tailwind AI first AI model
the moon landing is AI generates a
generative AI powered by generative AI
with AI at the center Leading Edge AI
research with Google's Ai and the cloud
personal AI building AI building
it's no surprise to see Google going all
in on AI in order to protect their core
search advertising business from openai
and Bing chat but they also announced
some amazing things for web and mobile
developers and in today's video we'll
look at 10 crazy announcements from
Google I O one generative AI is coming
directly to search engine result pages
and that means internet users will have
less of a reason to visit your website
to look for answers and that'll
completely change the way people think
about search engine optimization in the
future and it makes me wonder how
advertisements will be integrated into
these results two speaking of
advertisements one thing they didn't
tell you at i o is that they're
currently running a YouTube ad blocker
experiment that will prevent you from
using YouTube If you have ad blockers
enabled in other words it's an ad
blocker blocker but I've said too much
already three the biggest AI
announcement at i o was the release of
palm 2 Google's state-of-the-art model
to compete with gpt4 it comes in a
variety of sizes like gecko otter bison
and unicorn that trade off speed for
sophistication what's more exciting
though is that you have access to these
foundational models from Google Cloud's
ml Ops product vertex AI you can use
vertex to fine-tune your own models with
your own data and that's huge for
entrepreneurs who want to build their
own AI products it also has an
embeddings API and all kinds of other
useful stuff four we've got duet which
is bringing AI to all of Google's
business products like docs and sheets
it's the answer to Microsoft's co-pilot
I've been using it in Google Docs myself
and it's a total game changer for White
Collar productivity it's not quite as
good as gpt4 but currently it's only
using the Bison model I guess we'll see
what happens when they unleash the
unicorn in addition these models can
write code and they're being integrated
directly into Ides like Android Studio
they demoed Studio bot which can write
and analyze code but most importantly
debug crashes that's cool but not quite
as cool as number five project Tailwind
which is Tailwind CSS built natively
into the Chrome browser actually no that
that's not right I wish but it's
actually just another AI product you can
think of it as Google Drive where you
store a bunch of documents that are
automatically trained as your own custom
AI model that'll be incredibly useful
for cheating on your homework or if
you're too broke to hire a lawyer you
could use it to analyze all the legal
documents in in your case tools like
that will be huge in the future but now
it's time to move out of the AI realm
six Google announced a foldable phone
it'll cost you about two racks and now
apple is the only company that doesn't
have a foldable seven Firebase updates
hosting now supports a bunch of new
Frameworks like svelt kit Knox Astro and
flutter web firestore now supports ore
queries Cloud functions got a python
runtime and they released a bunch of new
extensions to access AI tools like the
Palm API check out my second channel for
a full tutorial on all this stuff soon
8. flutter announced a new version that
has full support for the new material 3
design spec that's good news for mobile
developers but number nine is even
better webassembly for managed memory
languages garbage collected languages
like Dart and kotlin will be able to
compile to webassembly which means they
can run natively in the browser tools
like flutter can already transpile to
JavaScript but webassembly is up to
three times faster they actually demoed
a react developer's worst nightmare a
flutter app running inside of an angular
app and sharing State between the two
and finally that brings us to number 10
web GPU a new API that allows the
browser to to access the GPU this API
has been in the works for a while but
can now be enabled in Chrome with a
feature flag it's basically a
replacement for webgl will make it
easier and faster to run 3D graphics and
do machine learning directly in the
browser it'll improve libraries like 3js
and can already make tensorflow.js Run
100 times faster and that's it for our
show tonight tune in tomorrow for more
AI Gore now here it is your moment of
sand you're so excited to make the moon
Bender with AI generative AI thank you